We will be looking at some calculus notation. Now.
We want delve to in delve too much into calculus.
but
you know, it's something we have to talk about.
And where possible we will leave it. We will use calculators
to do things like derivatives and
integration very quickly. Let's talk
about the two major Concepts in calculus.
differentiation integration
Okay, so even if like I said and if you're not familiar with
Calculus or you do not remember calculus at
all. Don't worry about it. Like I said, we will look at the notation, but we
won't do much.
You know operations with Calculus. We will skip to the value. We'll skip
to the results.
So what are the two major Concepts and calculus?
The first one is differentiation.
Okay, I'm gonna get to why?
we have to
You know talk about this.
the idea of differentiation
and calculus
is
to find
the
this slope
of a point
at a curve
see if we will if we were trying to find the slope of
you know straight.
Lines, it wouldn't be a problem.
But what curve it's a bit problematic?
Now without getting too deep into differentiation
and limits and
the notation all of that. The point of differentiation is
simply Define this point to find a particular
point at a curve and that is referred to as the gradient. That's number one.
What we more concerned with.
is integration in this
in this Workshop in the context of continuous probability distributions.
We work considered with integration.
Which is the second part the second major Concept in calculus?
So whereas differentiation is about finding the
gradient.
of a curve
the line
integration is about measuring the area.
Under that very same curve.
So what is the area?
Of this particular region, if this was
again, if this if we were looking at straight shapes, it wouldn't be
a problem.
But with curved we have to we have
to take a
you know, we have to do it in a special way.
As a matter of fact the idea is that you would take
let's say this area.
the one indicated by these red boxes
and then you would zoom into that area. You would zoom into
that area and you would create these slices so
he would take for example this Regional use my
Marquee tool you would take this area.
For example.
You would slice it.
And then you would slice it further and then slice it some
more and that's nice to some more you will keep on going like this infinitely.
Until your slice is so thin.
it's so thin that
the top part of that slice is
virtually straight
Okay.
And you keep on doing this repeatedly over
and over and over until you have covered the entire area
that you're trying to calculate with these thin slices and then
you add those slices up.
And that's how you get these service. That's how
you get the area of under the Curve.
Now we may have a workshop where we talk about calculus exclusively
and trigonometry, of course in a
separate Workshop. But you know today is about statistics and probability Theory
so we won't get it that very much, but I just
want to remind you.
What in differentiation integration are
about?
And how we will help us.
with continuous
probability distributions